حظر وشيك يتعرض له تطبيق تيك توك في
الولايات المتحده بعد التهديد الاخير
بالبيع او الحظر الكامل ومعارضه الحكومه
الصينيه الخطط الامريكيه لاجبار الملاك
على بيعه عواقب القرار الامريكي المرتقب
لا تواجه الشركه الصينيه فحسب بل طالت
المعلنين
فعائدات التطبيق الصيني من الاعلانات في
الولايات المتحده في ازدياد غير مسبوق قد
تصل هذه العائدات الى سته مليارات وثمائه
مليون دولار هذا العام بحسب شركه انسايدر
انتلجنس للابحاث حيث يحظى التطبيق بشعبيه
واسعه ويملك حاليا 150 مليون مستخدم شهريا
في الولايات المتحده
الامر الذي سيجعل هؤلاء المعلنين يراقبون
مصير ازمه تيك توك عن كثب قبل ان يقرروا
الاعلان في التطبيق
تتعرض الشركه لضغوط متزايده من مسؤولين
ونواب امريكيين بسبب مخاوف تتعلق بالامن
القومي
وتحديدا في بيانات المستخدمين التي يرون
انها قد تقع في يد الحكومه الصينيه رغم
تاكيد الرئيس التنفيذي لتيك توك ان الشركه
لم تشارك ابدا هذه البيانات وهي نفس التهم
التي تواجهها المنصه في عدد من دول اوروبا
التي قامت بحظر التطبيق جزئيا